once you have a kid morning sex bye-bye
yeah really i'm not a big morning sex
guy i feel like that's when you're at
your worst i used to love you i just you
know yeah i'm asexual yeah yeah yeah
what do you mean why morning sex well
just because the kid ends up in your bed
every morning they're like wake up
before you you want to go back to sleep
you bring them to the bed
breastfeeding it's not really sexy yeah
you guys did the pregnancy porn too that
was well that's like the one category i
don't go to i've never watched it either
but she she was so determined she wanted
to keep working up until she was like
six months in we did one scene where she
was so huge and just full of babies yeah
that she was just like
you [ __ ] emily willis
i'm sitting here i can barely breathe
you took maternity leave basically
but like okay so when i was pregnant it
was peak pandemic and that was the best
time for only fans like the numbers were
just through the roof every other
stimulus check you set the record right
i mean those were my record months for
sure okay like i was not gonna stop
working
yeah so it was just i'm pregnant but
we're killing it with money and then
there are people who are probably extra
freaky want to see the pregnancy stuff
can you feel the baby kick is that weird
like you got your hand on it it's like
giving you pounds
what am i saying
you know what do people think about it
[Laughter]
i don't remember the truth is i really
don't remember do you guys think you've
completely revolutionized how people see
porn
no in terms of in terms of stigma
i i think you i think the only family's
revolution as a whole has and i think
she was very very early on to be like a
normal person who just started the only
fans and like the level of attention
that she got when she first started
was insane because it just really felt
like you were a normal person who chose
to do only fans of private snap at the
time yeah and there was definitely like
something about that whereas i feel like
the public is maybe a little
disillusioned to that now where they
realize like oh they can make a ton of
money that's why they're doing it oh
yeah i think maybe it's like the number
hits and then american greed like that's
like baked into our dna we start saying
oh that's a reasonable way to make money
like like we're totally fine like with a
pharmaceutical company we're totally
fine with i'm sure you guys have gone
through these like moral gymnastics
where you're like oh there are things
that should be scrutinized but they're
not and this thing is very heavily
scrutinized well a lot of only fans
girls get to like you know 20k a month
or something and they're like oh i've
made it i'm done we're we're the greedy
ones who are actually like no how are we
gonna take this to the next level and
really make a real [ __ ] business out
of it and then that's like the mentality
that led us to like well maybe we could
do a podcast that's also a porno and
this is plugtalk onlyplugtalk.com okay
so this is
i mean plug everything i'm i cause i do
it no that's fine okay
[Music]
plug talk plug talk interview the porn
star
have sex with her afterwards yes keep
the mics on no we switched to the boom
mic which is so annoying because it
would be nice to just [ __ ] but you got
to deal with the headset thing now are
do do you need like i don't know how
your system works but like do you need
to like
you need some performance-enhancing
drugs
everybody asked me though
come on i've never been like done
you know no i wouldn't okay i would
never want him to do that he doesn't do
that wait why not why not because all
those guys when you see like we've had
other guys come on set to [ __ ] girls and
they're like
brb they're i'm gonna do another viagra
like in the middle of [ __ ] like they
rely on it the same way people rely on
like adderall for studying you feel like
they can't do it without the drug
anymore you know
[Music]
[Music]
you